Прихід IKEA в Україну президент Петро Порошенко
пов'язує з поліпшенням інвестиційного клімату в державі.
За його словами, фірмовий меблевий магазин у торговому центрі
вирішили нарешті відкрити,
"коли IKEA знайшла надійних партнерів за сприяннядержави,
констатуючи покращення інвестиційного клімату".
DW перевірила,
У рейтингу Doing Business від Світового банку,
на який орієнтуються інвестори, обираючи країну для вкладень,
Україна за останні роки дійсно покращила свої позиції.
Зокрема, торік була на 76-мумісці серед 190 країн.
Тоді як у докризовому 2013-му - лише на 112-му місці.
Автори оприлюдненого на сайті Держдепартаменту США
Огляду інвестиційного клімату в Україні на 2018 рік наголошують,
що проведені українським урядом реформи принесли макроекономічну стабільність.
Однак рівень прямих іноземних інвестицій в країну, за їхніми даними, залишається низьким.
"Чисті" вкладення торік дорівнювали лише двом відсоткам ВВП, йдеться у документі.
Корупцію та недовіру до судової системи інвестори називають
найбільш знаковими перепонами для заходу на український ринок.
Ці ж чинники очолюють рейтинг основних бар'єрів для іноземних вкладників
вже третій рік поспіль, заявили у Європейській Бізнес Асоціації.
За оцінками Transparency International,
Україна торік посіла 130-те місце серед 180-ти країн у світовому Індексі сприйняття корупції.
За цим рейтингом, Україна - найкорумпованіша країна в Європі після Росії.
Поступове втілення реформ покращує інвестиційний клімат в Україні,
і вона піднімається в міжнародних рейтингах.
Втім, рівень прямих вкладень залишається невисоким
через корупцію та недовіру до судової системи.